hey youtubers it's Charlie so we have
new firestorm footage and danielle
panabaker was talking about killer frost
as well as gorilla grodd things
happening so so I felt like it demanded
a video I'm also gonna be doing the QA
at the end of this - so here's the deal
with gorilla grodd danielle panabaker
was just doing a whole bunch of press on
a bunch of different outlets so what she
said is is that the garage story this
year I mean she didn't say exactly when
it's coming but she said it's gonna be
like this King Kong allegory where
she'll play like the and arrow character
so just you know picture of Gorilla
Grodd jumping around town over buildings
trying to hold her in his hand rewind -
last year the the Grodd lives episode I
think it was 21 where they have general
Eiling in the prison and Grodd is
speaking through his lips and he says
Kate good so that means that Grodd likes
Caitlin snow probably just because she
treated him really well when he was a
test subject maybe she just brought him
big belly burgers we know he doesn't
like bananas but that's what's going on
with Grodd this year so I don't think
we're gonna see so Lavar I don't think
we're gonna see gorilla City I think
it's just gonna be another standalone
Grodd episode what I'm really curious to
see is if you know because earth - in
the portal the speed gun however you
want to think about it is such a big
deal like a running plotline I'm curious
to see if Grodd story overlaps with that
like if Grodd finds out about the earth
2 portal and tries to do something with
it but the other big thing is the fury
of firestorm so here's what's going on
it's gonna be like a multiple firestorm
battle royale episode we know now that
this character is going to be Jax
Jackson they actually they changed his
name again originally it was just J
Jackson that a lot of people thought it
might be a recast version of jason rusch
the the thing that i think they're doing
think the reason i think that they're
not using jason rusch is just because
they want to keep it as simple as
possible like they don't want to recast
the actor but they don't think that the
actors that they already cast as jason
rusch is right for the tone of legends
of tomorrow like they want a stronger
actor and they don't want to recast so
that might be why they created this new
character because they want this actor
he was then attacked the block with John
boyega who you know is burning it up in
the Star Wars universe right now so I
think they wanted him like they felt
like he would be the perfect firestorm
character but there was an issue with
the jason rusch name so they're like why
don't we just create a new firestorm
there is a point in the comics when a
bunch of people all over the world try
to get their hands on Martin Stein's
technology to create firestorm
for their own so like each nation has
their own version of firestorm is this
big debacle in the new 52 so you can
look at it from the perspective that
there have been many many people who
have been part of a firestorm matrix and
yes Ronnie will come back but they
didn't say how he come back I'm guessing
either in a flashback or earth to Ronnie
will be seen somehow and this may have
been another case where like where
robbie amell just wasn't available to do
legends of tomorrow because he's doing
so many movies so they're like okay we
want to use firestorm but we can't use
robbie amell so why don't we just do the
transition to the next version of the
character they actually have the actors
on set now from arrow the flash in
legends of tomorrow shooting all three
shows logistically behind the scenes
it's kind of a nightmare shooting three
shows at the same time with all the same
actors but it is gonna look freaking
awesome whenever it gets here next year
it should air sometime in January I
don't know exactly how many episodes
firestorm is gonna be in this year but
presumably they brought Tom Cavanagh
back like Harrison wells came through
the portal so that Martin Stein can go
away like they want to have that role
filled in the cast like they want like
the older adviser character so they're
bringing back Tom Cavanagh kind of like
passing the torch from Martin Stein to
Harrison wells
and in case you didn't hear me talk
about it in my flash episode 3 video
Harrison wells of earth 2 is not evil
he's not gonna be zoom he's just a super
big Grant Gustin when he when
he was talking about the character just
said he was a total douchebag but he is
the original version of Harrison wells
of Earth 2 he's not gonna be a Oh Bart
Thawne in disguise but Matt Ledyard the
guy who played a Barth on before he kind
of like sucked in the DNA of Harrison
wells he's gonna be back to Eddie is
gonna be back to but we don't know how
that's gonna work either presumably
it'll all be flashbacks and earth to
stuff ok so here we go question time jr
sanchez asks does blue lightning at the
stadium the reverse-flash versus the
flash fight have anything to do with
professor zoom and flash or anyone else
so I think you might be talking about
zoom specifically like professor zoom
and zoom are two different characters so
if you're asking about blue lightning
zoom during season one no that's just a
coincidence there have been times in the
comics where zoom in professor zoom team
up to work together reluctantly like
professor zoom hates the crap out of
zoom but I don't think that that was
what they were trying to do and season
one of the flash it was just meant to be
a Barth on professor zoom and actually I
know there been a lot
theories about who zoom is I mean it
still hasn't been confirmed we still
won't find out who's beneath the mask
but they keep referring to him using
male pronouns so I don't think that it
is a female character next question will
free Castillo asks I want to see a race
between Jay and Wally soon or soon we're
just talking about all the flashes
Justice have a race I do think that they
will have that moment like the
schwarmann moment at the end of the
season when they all have a race
together like hey let's see who's the
fastest Jay is still trying to get his
powers back but they just introduced the
idea of this porc matter like the
special matter that's involved in
getting back through the portal so I
think that's gonna be critical to
getting Jays powers back but they still
don't know how soon took his powers like
I mean that's one of the Speed Force
abilities most speedsters can give and
take speed Wally West was able to do it
in the comics but they might change the
explanation just for the TV show it was
changes a few minor things about the
comics so just don't assume comic book
rules when it comes to giving and taking
speed so once everybody gets their speed
back and once Wally West gets his powers
then we will probably see team flash bro
down next question Ballentine asks do
you think that Henry Allen from earth 2
could be zoom maybe earth to Henry Allen
kidnapped and killed Barry's father and
took his place
oh so you're talking about like Henry
Allen from Earth 2 coming to earth 1 and
then killing Barry's dad in the prison
or like outside of the prison and then
just walking around asks his dad
pretending to be him the reason I don't
think that's the case although it's a
really awesome idea I'd love to see John
Wesley Shipp be the villain to the
season he looks like he's about the same
size as Jay Garrick and Jay Garrick is
pretty tall but until we get some more
evidence I mean it's really only a
couple episodes in so we'll get a lot
more evidence about what zoom is up to
what he's doing and why he wants to be
the fastest once we learned those things
but we'll have some better theory
crafting material but the reason I think
that he is a West is because season 1
was all about Barry fixing his family
like he wanted to get his dad out of
prison save his mother he accomplished
that now in season 2 whose family is
broken
well irises family is broken so it's all
about fixing that family so I think that
it might be a West from earth to trying
to fix that but because it's earth 2
it's really hard to tell I mean it could
totally be evil version of Barry the
really interesting thing and I think
this is telling is that none of the
writers none of the actors have
it's about the characters meeting
themselves on earth too so like is there
an earth - version of Barry or is he
dead like what's going on so I think
we'll also have to meet other versions
of the characters from earth - before we
can say you know zoom is XYZ character
next question
HK Harpster asks I think Wally's gonna
come midseason finally yeah that's
interesting we don't know which episode
he's gonna debut in and the really
interesting thing is is that Jay Garrick
I guess he hasn't met the west's yet so
I'm really interested to see if Wally is
from Earth - and Jay Garrick meets
detective West on earth one and he's
like oh hey I've met your son and he's
like what I don't have a son next
question
Noah plays asks what if zoom is Barry
from the future when he was blue trying
to kill all the speedsters to stop
something like when he tried to kill his
past self so you're talking about the
new 52 plotline though the reason I
don't think that zoom is from the future
now is because everything is about like
different choices different versions of
the characters so I think that zoom is
just a different version of a character
that we already know it's like season 1
was all about time travel season 2 is
all about alternate versions of
characters so I just I think the zoom is
gonna flow from that thank you so much
for so many questions everyone and
congratulations to Nova blast you win
this week's reverse flash ring be sure
to private message me on the back end of
my channel so I get your contact info
the next round of the giveaway will will
start next Tuesday whenever I post my
flash episode 4 video just just like
normal I know I'm still behind on Gotham
I'm trying to get that out as soon as
possible hopefully I'll get it out
before Doctor Who starts tomorrow in the
meantime in case you guys haven't seen
it I just posted like the full Jessica
Jones trailer it's like a full two and a
half minute trailer you can click here
to watch that like 5 or 6 times is gonna
be so dark and gritty int you can click
here for this week's episode of arrow in
the flash thank you so much for watching
everybody let's that five I'll see you
guys tomorrow